i feel like there's funny funny pictures
on instagram of
what we think spiritual growth looks
like and what it actually looks like and
it's like
unicorns and rainbows and [ __ ] like this
is what it looks like
yoga meditation the beach mustang
but what does it really look like what
does spiritual growth
really look like i believe that each and
every one of us has the power within
ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today is a special episode with my
friend stacy barnes who
i've been friends with for 15 years and
we've really really grown together
as people um and as uh
as just citizens of the world and and
and and having a little introspection
with the way that we operate and the way
that we think and so
when we're together we just we just go
off i mean we can talk just
we just talk for hours and hours and
hours and it never ends and it's always
a very deep dive so
i thought it would be really fun to do
a show with her and just dive into one
word
so the word of the day today is
transition
and the word really is meant to make you
just understand what it's like to
transition through difficult times and
we're just going to share
some of our experiences and some of the
ways that it may feel to you
enjoy transition is something that
you know the initiation is the growth
like that's your that's the call
but then the the root of you know
what is happening after that is the
transition and i think that the
the transition is where people get
scared like the transition is where
people
retreat the transition is where you
think maybe
oh i feel so bad maybe this isn't the
right thing and
the transition is is to me
where where you lose where people get
lost
um for me i remember back when i was
like retiring
and dealing with relationship issues and
all kinds of stuff
and i felt like absolute
[ __ ] i mean i was crying i was on the
phone crying to you for
hours i was um i was
i was questioning my decisions i was you
know
i was questioning questioning the people
around me and their
and their what they thought of
everything going on
um i i was so uncomfortable i remember i
kept saying i was like if i could just
like go to sleep and wake up in three
months
it would be really good um the good news
is is that that
the deeper the feeling the bigger the
the bigger the
the release the bigger the transition in
a positive way those things don't hap
like you don't feel that bad because
you are gonna they're not they're not a
bad sign like crying
being emotional like i know that you
like that resonates with you because
you're an emotional person so
you know but that transitions that
transition stuff is where we lose people
completely because the transition isn't
necessarily pretty
and in order to be in the space
of transition
it takes that inward work that we have
to do and it takes the feelings that are
coming through
and i was hearing it's truth
it's just i was hearing about how you
know basically how to manifest
and how it starts with an idea which is
like the call to growth
right that's like okay i want this to be
different in my life i want to do this
better
yeah and then the next phase is the the
making how you make that happen which is
the transition
and then and then all that's left after
that
is what you've asked for to manifest
you've done nearly all the work and it's
been called into action in the universe
and that energy and that frequency of
what you're asking for is on its way
you have requested it it's happening
you've thought about it you're working
on it and all that's left to happen
is the good part yeah right
exactly right like so the good part is
what's left but you got to go through
deep [ __ ]
exactly and that's the good part it's
interesting the work
for me the work and which is something
that
for you i mean it's a beautiful thing
that
that you inspire me and so many with is
that
you're really you're willing to do the
work that's true i am
and fear which is something that holds
me back
is something that activates you
yeah that's probably true actually very
true i think you're probably right
because i think of i when i feel a fear
i feel maybe it's maybe the competitive
part of me goes it's a challenge
maybe that's part of it um it also
shows me a weakness and i don't really
like being weak
no you i pick up them dumbbells girl
it is and i think the beautiful thing
that
that you did learn and that that came
through with your career
career tool-wise is to feel
into where it's weak or where you're
feeling driven i mean that was literally
my job was to fight
right literally and people actually said
that it was a moving meditation for me
probably i had an astrologer tell me
that
that was probably my my moving
meditation the whole my whole life and i
was like
wow right because it's kind of out of
body
and never you're so present you're not
like you can't plan the race so you're
just reacting
anyway keep going no that was really
interesting i was like man that's like
you're right you're probably right
it's so good which is why i'm so called
to like hike with the girls walk with
the dogs
yeah say girls and my dogs and like go
on walks
just like anything that gets me into
like a quiet rhythmic mode where i can
just kind of like
zone out zone in zone out tune in
anyway literally yeah yeah so
um yeah so the
the fear and i try what i've been
learning is how do i use
feelings as um teachers
versus triggers so how how do i
if i'm feeling sad it's it's coming
through to teach me something it's
coming through asking for growth and
that expansion but what is it
um if i'm feeling fear
it's very common for me to retreat and
go back and just get really quiet
and how do i shift that how do i pivot
from that old way
yeah of reacting and you definitely have
taught me
a lot in the fact of don't be afraid of
fear
and feelings are not just
feelings but but fear is just a feeling
and if i if i
choose to let that keep me small
versus expanding in other ways um
so i don't do it as quick as you do but
i certainly learn from that and i
and i know if i can do it at my pace and
at my process and i do
need some support you know whether it's
reaching out to you or my therapist or
talking to my husband or friend whomever
it is sometimes i need a little bit of
support in
doing that but um it's okay to ask for
that yeah and
and to have that and say okay what is
you know here's what i'm feeling around
this
is this real or is this just something
coming through that's asking me to
evolve through
just an old pattern an old way and
typically every time
so what i've learned with fear
is that she's one of my teachers
and i definitely try to see
and feel the fear differently than
what i once did and for for many many
years that one's hard for me to
to i think that's always going to be
an ongoing process i literally believe
that um because it's
it's so um
challenging i remember when i was um i
remember when i was contemplating on
hosting the espys
and i was talking to everybody and
everybody kept saying they're like
because i would say i'm scared like i
don't know if i can do that i'm not
funny
i'm not an actor i'm not a singer i'm
not a dancer
um i am not any of those things that
presents on stage and i was like i just
don't know i just don't know if i can do
it
and i'm like it's scared i'm like i want
to but i just don't know and i remember
everybody was saying you and everybody
was saying like
who are you to not who are you to not
sign up for something that's scary
that's what you do i'm like oh [ __ ]
thanks for reflecting that because
that's that was that was totally true
but
um but i had to um i had to sit in that
feeling and
and and and say yes i really believe in
this concept that if something scares
you
and excites you equally
don't let the fear win you you can see
it clearer i mean
you have a clear vision on it's pretty
it's almost like the contrast between it
and then you see what it is and it's
just for you it's just it's just
i've also you feel and see the truth
very it's it's instantly and so you can
see what's coming through around yeah
with fear
yeah exactly um i've also heard that
in your thoughts that you can't have two
conflicting thoughts happening at the
same time
you can only have one so if you feel
fear that's the only emotion you have
if you feel love excitement truth
whatever it may be that's positive that
is the only
energy that's resonating with you like
you can't be scared and excited really
all
you're either picking one of the other
it doesn't mean you don't flip back and
forth but you really can only feel one
at one time and that hit home like i was
like man that's kind of interesting
right because if you just keep
choosing one over and over again right
you can't right now you can't
be excited and then be fearful at the
same time it's
not really no you're just excited now it
doesn't mean that your mind doesn't
and the ego doesn't take over all the
sudden and make you go oh but what about
this girl don't you
don't you remember this and don't you
remember when you were hurt this one
time protect yourself
and like that's what pulls us back from
transitioning is
the ego and the old stories we tell each
other
i love talking to uh joe dispenza about
the mind and listening to his stuff
because
um it's so crazy how he says that we
like we get addicted to a thought
pattern like we get addicted to
we get addicted hormonally to thinking
something and
and our body is wired and fired to
request that
and feed off of that and so um there's a
there's a discomfort in shifting that
um also that our thoughts over time
become completely
made up as well like we can have one
experience and then over the course of
time it's either only
half true or less than half true um
which is crazy to think too because then
we're just telling ourselves really
fictitious
stories so we might as well make up a
damn good one
but we don't because we're addicted to
the hormone produced so
but the transition i mean i guess like
i feel like it's important for people to
understand what the transitions feel
like because
for me and you've talked about this
before about like
like birthing like that's how you
described it and i was like
okay and you speak above my head half
the time until i catch up and then you
start talking about my head again and
then i catch up but
like this whole birthing process maybe
that's i know what you mean but for me
i think the more descriptive word is
convulsions
like it's like it's like my body i've
had a few experiences where
when i'm going through a transition
whether it be a big one that's
fundamental about whether it be
work or relationships or living or
whatever it may be there's those but
then there's also just a thought pattern
there's also just a realization that's
going on in your life where you're like
i remember one time i was my stomach
hurt really like i was eating and
every time i ate my stomach hurt really
bad
and it got worse over the course of two
days and i thought what
on earth is wrong with me and then i
remember i was
texting i was texting aaron about like
you know
i was heading out to green bay and i was
packing my bags again
and i'd hit like that emotion of i
just i'm always willing to compromise
and leave and move and that
vulnerability that comes with packing up
again was
so um it was just there it was sitting
in my solar plexus and it was like
cranking on my stomach and every bite i
took was a reminder of like dealing with
that emotion
and in one message i had sent
him like it came pouring out and i was
like oh my god i didn't realize the
problem because
i'm good at packing i'm good at leaving
i'm good at being vulnerable
i'm good at compromising i'm good at all
those things and i'm good at handling
[ __ ] i'm good at dealing with a lot of
things going on good a lot good with
transition even
but like this one was a feeling and this
so i'll finish this and i'll
expand but so as soon as
i acknowledged it which is part of your
rain word which is acknowledge what's
going on as soon as i acknowledged what
it was that was actually going on
to me it was really realizing yeah i
started bawling and going into
convulsions and crying i wrote in my
journal
and then i sure enough i woke up the
next morning and i felt
totally fine crazy right how our body
can manifest a feeling that we're having
in a real
tangible way and so this has happened on
a few levels like there's been other
times too where i will arrive at a
conclusion
about a troubling situation like i
remember it was like you know a
situation about relationships and it was
like
you know when i finally arrived on the
like like the big topic of like
being a maybe i was like oh my god
that's what it is and like i went into
convulsions and i was crying and i
almost couldn't breathe
and so like there are times where i
realize what the problem is and it like
it's a body reaction and so that's why
sometimes your emotions can come
out in a large way and probably if it's
something that you
don't even want to talk about yep it's
going to be
gigantic there you go stuff you don't
want to talk about it
and say out loud which is why in my book
there's also a section on
you know saying things out loud because
you you then bring it to the surface and
like you taught me like you pull that
energy and that emotion
through and out of you and so you you
it's like
again if we think of our bodies as a
body of energy which it is if you
condensed all
all matter between humans and the world
it's like the size of an apple and
neil degrasse tyson confirmed that
there's not there's like the density of
us is not there we're just energy so if
you think about our bodies like that
then you think about how you can
transition that energy
move the energy i mean that's what yoga
and tantric and kundalini practices are
it's
breathing is about moving energy so if
you can just
pull that energy from wherever it's
sitting in whatever's
energy center in your body or chakra
whatever you want to call it
then you pull that out of you and it
really is gone
and you also take away the power when
you talk about it
right you do you you disarm it yeah
well bringing it sharing the truth and
bringing it to surface
allows allows it to just actually
it's real so a lot of things that we
hold in
and that we're not ready to release
for fear or or whatever those reasons
are
um it almost keeps us to a certain
extent
imprisoned it's like they're in charge
of us and so we adapt
in ways so we don't have to feel the
abandonment or we don't have to feel
the sadness or less than or not being
seen or whatever
whatever it is that comes through so i
don't even want to discuss it and that's
why for you
when you were describing about what was
coming through
is is and it was such a visceral
body gut feeling because
you are continuing to be in this
expansive space and you continue to open
but when you do that
you feel more and it's coming through
and it's showing itself and it's
it's just it's it was it's it was time
and the beautiful thing is is that
you're using these other tools that
you've brought into your life
that support you through your self-care
and the work that you're doing
for from within so you knew oh my gosh
and it was just
you were able to not just have your head
tell you it's the food
that's that's upsetting my belly it was
something totally different
and because you knew it was a different
energy you could feel it from a
different place
and from that you went and you journaled
and and all
so much came out and that's why it is
what did you call it convulsions
yeah right and for me it's it's birthing
and it's like
contractions and what's happening so
literally the same thing because
it's it's i'd like to think something's
dying instead of giving birth to it so
maybe that's it
no i i totally agree well there is right
i mean you're you
you're either rebirthing yourself like
you're right yes
right or you're letting go and letting
it just die away
of an old belief system so it's all in
perspective and they're both
they're both in truth and it actually
matters what's coming through for you
around it um and when you can even
notice
oh this is a new level of consciousness
that's coming in that's asking to be
embodied
that's asking to be communicated and
then for me fear comes through and uh oh
what's that gonna do to my relationships
and how's this gonna feel and am i gonna
look more like spacey stacy
or i don't know and i'm like but shoot i
know if i stay in
that it just that i'm going to get
called my [ __ ]
also with that so it's just interesting
that it's
just a freaking process and
so yeah transition is powerful
it's scary it's um
uncomfortable and
just what i've noticed is being able to
communicate about it
us being able to relate it's like we're
going through our own shifts it's like
okay that feels good
but then communicating with our partners
and people who were within life
also so they understand that's
definitely was a problem that i
had in my head right like i wasn't
communicating to him i just i buried
like everything that i was feeling
and i was burying it for myself too not
not just from him or anyone else like
i didn't like you said like i didn't
want to go there so i just buried and
buried of course
so of course disconnection happened yes
and um
[ __ ] i need to like own up to my own
stuff yeah yeah you see that yeah i had
lost myself and then how did i
go on how to cope right because it's
like not
it's not easy to take it all on yourself
so
when it's a transition time for me um
you almost have to go you you have to
you i mean i'm not great at meditating i
feel like there's a there's opportunity
there for understanding i'm not great at
it i'm more of a writer walker
talker thinker i would like to expand
more into that into meditation because
it's so powerful
according to anyone who does it
regularly
but you know when i'm in a time of
transition look i call upon my
girlfriends
i call upon you others family
whoever you really trust and can be
vulnerable with
um they come into the picture
writing and journaling comes into the
picture
spending some time some quiet time alone
stop with the distractions
stop with the stuff that pulls you away
stop with the egoic
things that pull you away from what your
soul
is asking you to face
it's easy right you can pick up your
phone you can go to do it make a dinner
date you can drink
you can um i mean all of these things
are going to
take you away from your ultimate goal so
in a time of transition
um when you're starting to feel
something feel something weird
i'm trying to put it into words like if
you haven't dealt with some something
like this but like
if you just kind of feel not right or
not
on or not like syncing up with your
partner
um or even your job like when you just
feel out of sync
that can be your your signal to face
something that you're about to
transition through
yep and um rings true my recommendation
like
like they always say with spirituality
like spiritual growth i feel like
there's funny
funny pictures on instagram of what we
think spiritual growth looks like and
what it actually looks like and it's
like
unicorns and rainbows and [ __ ] like this
is what it looks like
yoga meditation the beach
but what does it really look like what
does spiritual growth really look like
it looks like i'm crying box of clean
eggs
[ __ ] mess like i mean just like
going through the [ __ ] yep and it
it it isn't pretty but here's the other
thing about spiritual growth
is that once it started for me and so
for me i guess it was like it was really
when we started our girls trips in 2013
so
that was probably the really like the
big start of it all and then probably
really in 2015 on our little sedona trip
that was probably like the next level of
it so it's been
you know in that sort of um
four to six range four to six year range
of transition
um but um but it's like
it's
nothing you can quit once you start yeah
you never turn back no and i don't know
anyone that started on a spiritual
journey of the journey to the self
that has turned back i don't either i
think that's
there's religious people that turn away
you can be in a religion and turn away
because again in my opinion it's not
about the self
it's about outward like oh uh you know
what can you do for i mean like look
doing things for others is great
but when you really turn the mirror
around on yourself and look and go
why did you react like that where is
that coming from
what do you need to face where do you
need to grow it's not someone else's
fault
if you just start assuming that the what
what is happening
in your life is your fault
now that's the bad word is your
responsibility to
understand you grow
period and you'll transition and then
you'll end up on the other side
it's going to come again though and
that's the that's the fun part is that
it's about the it's about the process
it is and knowing and accepting that
this is an
ongoing process yeah um
i do believe we both can attest to this
that we're feeling
it's it's it's still deep and difficult
and mucky
right and totally mind blows us
but we're getting a little bit more
comfortable with it we're we're
yep yeah it's kind of like your workouts
like it's like the ice bucket right you
find you did that you did that you did
the hot and cold and yeah um
thank you for encouraging me and
believing in me but that's right like
like gabby says even about the ice
bucket she's done it as i said
no less than 500 she's probably done 5
000 times i don't even know
she's like it's never easy yeah but you
just get used to it
it's true it's and that's basically i
mean you held that space for me you were
like you want to what
not going to sugar coat it but i know
you can do it
yeah and yeah you know and you so
beautifully held that space for me so
thank you so much because and
and trust is such a huge thing with me
for any relationships i think that's
with anybody but that's something that
um is not a question in our um
in our friendship that's our sisterhood
and that's i knew
when you took me into that 220 degree
sauna
um and we were supposed to be in there
for what 12 minutes yeah
i was like whoo and heat's always a
little bit harder for me than cold like
i'm a snowboarding i'm a mountain girl
even though i live in arizona i'm always
going here i'm during the summer because
it's so stinking hot it's like
suffocating for me
yeah and so for me it was the um truth
barrel
yeah the truth barrel that was yeah and
i remember just looking over you and
you're like dripping and i'm dripping
and i'm like i feel like my nose is
gonna like the tip of my nose is gonna
burn off
but she would she my sister would let me
know and so we're good and so getting
there your nose is still there yeah so
the feelings that were coming through
and through the head and through the
body and it's like
trust trust and we did it and you guided
beautifully and you're like now
it's time you gave me all the
expectations what what to do
all the tools had that this is a simple
example of life but
yeah which is why i love having guides
but you guided me through something
that i almost said no to because i was
fearful
and you were like you have to have i
mean you have to have people that you
trust in your transitions
yeah and you know that will become more
and more you
but it will never be only you because um
i think in life we are meant to have
friends companions we're meant to share
and um so that's why we want to share
what kind of [ __ ] you have to go through
to transition that's right
it's all good though it's all good
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button